yo bailé en relación a la decisión de
los jueces del tribunal supremo con una
bici ética declaración para el
presidente la decisión de dejar que
tejas promulgó una ley de aborto muy
restrictiva
es un ataque sin precedentes a los
derechos constitucionales de las mujeres
esta decisión crea un caos
inconstitucional e insulta al estado de
derecho
el mandatario demócrata asegura que su
administración actuara rápidamente para
garantizar que las mujeres de texas
tengan un acceso seguro y legal al
aborto en el estado conservador muchas
mujeres han temido durante mucho tiempo
este endurecimiento de la ley tenemos
una pandemia que hace estragos fallos en
la red una tormenta que mató a gente
hemos tenido todos estos problemas aquí
en texas y sin embargo están ocupados
prohibiendo el aborto a partir del
miércoles posiblemente las mujeres de
texas ya no podrán abortar después de
las 6 semanas de embarazo salvo en casos
de peligro para la salud de la mujer
ahora más del 85% de los abortos se
realizan después de ese momento según la
planificación familiar aún más polémico
es el hecho de que el texto deja la
ejecución de la ley en manos de los
ciudadanos
hasta 10.000 dólares por denunciar
cualquier recurso al aborto tardío así
como a los médicos que lo realizan
tenemos derecho a demandar a las mujeres
y a las personas que las puedan ayudar a
abortar esto es completamente absurdo
el derecho al aborto en eeuu está
garantizado desde 1973 tras el famoso
caso de robo contra white pero ahora
mismo parece claramente amenazado por
algunos funcionarios electos
republicanos que están decididos a
endurecer la legislación en un momento
en el que el tribunal supremo de eeuu
está compuesto mayoritariamente por
jueces conservadores